[Music]
this is slime you might have expected
that from the title of the video even if
you didn't you might have just looked at
it and thought yeah yeah that looks like
slime slime has had a bit of a cultural
journey in the last few decades some of
us grew up watching green slime getting
dumped on the heads of game show
contestants and there's also been a bit
of a slime Renaissance recently with
entire YouTube channels and Instagram
accounts dedicated to teaching people
how to make their own gooey sticky blobs
at home with chemistry and a few simple
ingredients of course the most important
step in any of these slime projects is
saying it's a lie while you watch it
spread even when you know that of course
it's not actually alive the micro cosmos
on the other hand got to its experiments
long before we did giving us slime molds
a slime that not only lives it learns a
slime that fuses microbes together to
create a living thing that grows into
something we can observe with our own
eyes you may have seen slime molds
before their bodies sometimes laden with
spores as they grow on plants and
decaying wood they look kind of like
fungi and for that reason that is how
they were initially classified except
that one of the defining characteristics
of fungi is their inability to absorb
and digest their food internally slime
molds however are plenty capable of that
they do phagocytosis all the time where
we see decaying matter slime molds
detect a cornucopia of microbes plus
fungi do not move
and slime molds in their own unsettling
way do we know now that slime molds are
eukaryotes and they're made up of
amoeboid organisms but they don't fit
neatly into any of our definitions of
plant animal or fungus leaving them and
the more ambiguous Protista Kingdom and
clustered under the label my citas Oh up
however that label is a get this
polyphyletic grouping and that means
that the organisms
we've lumped together as slime molds
aren't necessarily all related they've
just found their way over the course of
evolution into a set of similarities
that is both convenient and misleading
in our attempts to categorize the
natural world there are three major
types of slime molds there are the proto
stella's which are the least studied
then there are the Dictyostelium molds
and then there's the mix oh my seat's
also known as the true or plasmodial
slime molds scientists love studying
slime molds particularly Dictyostelium
mix on my seats for reasons that we will
discuss soon
in fact the slime molds we're going to
show you today come from a lab though
we're on the hunt to see if we can
gather any of our own in our sampling
trips this species is physarum a poly
Cephalon a well study example of mixing
my seats making it a plasmodial slime
mold we feed it oatmeal and barley
flakes keeping it in the dark because
it's not particularly fond of light
we're observing our fi serum here on
petri dishes because it's hard to
transfer them to glass slides this in
turn limits our magnification so we
won't be able to see as deeply into
their bodies as we might be able to with
other organisms but they are remarkable
to observe as an entity with their
sprawling networked branches now we also
don't have samples of the other types of
slime molds right now so we're going to
be focusing our discussion mostly on
physarum and plasmodial slime molds but
both cellular and plasmodial slime molds
come up often in the news because
scientists have observed them doing very
impressive things but let's start out by
quickly explaining the differences here
cellular slime molds and the
Dictyostelium made up of organisms that
will likely spend most of their lives as
singular amoebas but if the conditions
around them become bleak these amoebas
team up to create a multicellular thing
called a slug that coordinates the
various cells so that they can all move
to a good spot and then morph into a
fruiting body that releases spores this
is wild right there are single cells and
then they get some signal that they
should all come together to form an
organism and spore out to create the
next generation but while cellular slime
molds are made up of many cells true
slime molds like physarum poly seffle 'm
are actually made up of only one cell
yeah all of that branching weirdness
that is all one cell the life of this
physarum started with the sporangia a
black blob Uhler body made by another
physarum
the sporangia holds spores that spread
and eventually germinate into either an
amoeba or a flagella at this unicellular
stage in their lives as you might expect
the physarum only has one nucleus but
then the amoeba finds another amoeba to
mate with and if you've heard about a
slime mold that
several hundred sexes this is where that
comes in each of the little cells
produced by the spores has two copies of
three sex genes and each of those sex
genes has their own variants across the
species taking into account the number
of different combinations of those sex
gene variants that are possible you end
up with an organism whose sex is just
one of hundreds which increases the
number of possible mating partners for
any individual physarum amoeba when they
do find their mate the two become one
literally they fused together
all the way down to their nucleus and
after this point the new organism
doesn't divide anymore it grows the
Plasmodium formed by the merged physarum
cells expands sometimes up to two feet
in diameter if the conditions are really
good but the nuclei inside will continue
dividing and dividing and dividing their
count ending up in the millions i serum
have actin and myosin or muscle proteins
the same ones we have that act as a part
of a network to contract and relax the
cytoplasm creating that stream you see
moving through the body of the organism
this process moves the slime mold which
can reach a speed of around four
centimeters an hour and it also helps
distribute nutrients around that
ever-widening increasingly gigantic body
and here's the thing whatever it is
these amoebas have come together to
create it is very very smart listing off
the physarum talents that have been
unearthed by scientists is enough to
inspire a sense of inadequacy they can
learn to manage uncomfortable stimuli
and pass on their knowledge to other
physarum by fusing with them
they can also solve mazes and make good
nutritional choices which like I can't
and one of the most well known physarum
experiments scientists placed oat flakes
down on an agar plate these flakes were
distributed in a pattern similar to the
arrangement of cities around Tokyo and
then they watched as a physarum that
started at the central Tokyo equivalent
eventually morphed itself into a route
that resembled shockingly closely the
Tokyo rail system the Phi serums
optimized hunt for food resembled the
efficiency that human engineers seek
when transporting people around cities
if you grew up watching Saturday morning
cartoons or even their blockbuster
adaptations you've seen plenty of robots
that assemble together into some kind of
mega robot the bodies are metal and
they're full of circuits transforming
the individual fantastical powers of
those robots into a bigger stompin
punching thing nature as it inevitably
seems to got their first beating even
our imaginations and with a touch that
is so much lighter than ours it's still
so incredible instead of imagined
mechanical frames it's the organic
bodies of amoeba assembling together to
create a bigger living learning thing
the contours are smooth the movements
streaming the slime mold doesn't need to
stomp or punch it just spreads and
consumes and fruits expanding the micro
cosmos in its own body as its takes
acclaim in our world
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us thank you to all of
our new viewers who are with us and
thank you especially to all of our
patrons on patreon who make this show
possible if you've just stumbled across
journey to the micro cosmos
these people on the screen right here
are the ones you really have to thank if
you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can find him
at Jam and germs on Instagram and if you
want to see more from us you can go to
youtube.com slash micro cosmos where we
have a new episode up every week